the year is 1968 a seven-year-old boy
named clay has just finished building a
contraption that remotely opens and
closes a little outside door for his
family's dog he is constantly building
toys and mechanical contraptions like
this one using spare bike parts old TVs
radios and any other objects he can get
his hands on eight years later the year
is 1976 the first personal computers hit
the market clay now 15 finds himself
immediately drawn to the newly
developing industry of computers he soon
begins creating software programs and as
a unique way of understanding how
technology and humans can interact
throughout his adolescence because of
this interest understanding and his
natural ingenuity clay creates and sells
several computer softwares develops a
software business appears on TV about a
dozen times meets the president and
graduates from MIT the year is 1982 clay
is 21 clay loses his mother to coronary
heart disease having not had a father in
the picture clays mother was one of the
few people clay had that he truly loved
and could count on in his life clay
struggles with his mother's death the
experience and idea of her death and
death in general makes no sense to him
clay wonders why a conscious intelligent
being unlike any other species dies like
every other species
how can a species that can create fire
tools computers airplanes rockets
medicine and so on still die basically
the same as a slug or a lizard early on
clay forms the belief that it doesn't
have to be this way he believes that in
the not so far future we can overcome
the dependence on our weak and entropic
biological human body through technology
clay embarks on his pursuit of this
belief he studies and develops his
theories and begins to immerse further
and further into newly emerging computer
softwares and bio technologies the year
is 1997 at age 36 clay starts a biotech
company named curve which creates
algorithms and computer models related
to human biology and genetics clay soon
discovers that the brain is quite
similar to the software's he's creating
and studying the brain with the brain
recognizes patterns organizes these
patterns hierarchal II and is then able
to formulate an awareness of its
conditions and make judgments
accordingly just like the newly
developing artificially intelligent
softwares clay is working with in this
clay realizes that if the coding of
human consciousness can be fully modeled
and replicated it could also be
theoretically placed onto any device of
replicable function and sustained
indefinitely in other words the human
experience of self could essentially be
limitless beyond the human body
thirty-two years later the year is 2029
at age 68 clay and his biotech company
successfully reverse-engineer the entire
function of the human brain this in
combination with a vast array of other
innovations in the biotechnology space
now means that human consciousness can
be enhanced maintained and transferred
through and on to any hardware device or
cloud service entity people now have the
opportunity to think and understand at a
rate that is exponentially greater than
any conceived possibility of the past
mental conditions are now able to be
modified beyond inherited genetics
lifelong mental disorders can be
eradicated bacterial and age-related
diseases can be circumvented eight years
later clay is now 76 the year as 2037
clay is the first person to successfully
upload his entire brain function to an
outside hybrid entity now at any point
clay can change over to a separate
synthetic body and reconnect to his
consciousness via a software access
server like the cloud and still remain
with his sense of self with this clay
would lead humanity into a new realm of
existence a life of boundless
consciousness the year is 24 8 e 6 clay
along with the rest of humanity lives
hundreds of years past a previously
standard life expectancy clay travels
the whole world and visits every place
there is to see he reads every book sees
every movie watches every video visits
every website masters every language
hears every story and learns every skill
he falls into love and out
love over and over hundreds of years
turned a thousands thousands turned to
millions the year becomes irrelevant
every time boredom overpopulation
overconsumption and so on appeared to be
on the horizon new worlds are discovered
and created clay explores new planets
new galaxies new dimensions
he meets new beings from other worlds
new realms of art science and
entertainment emerge and die emerge and
die he experiences new types of feelings
new ways of thinking new ways of
experiencing millions and millions more
years go by Clay's home his mother his
sister his dog his childhood his mortal
self the conditions of the world he was
born in have all along been forgotten
stored away like an old file on an old
hard drive he forgot he ever had clay
continues on for millions of years he
explores more worlds in more realms of
life on and on until eventually the
stars begin to die the galaxies begin to
dissolve and the universe begins to burn
out clay accomplished what had been but
a fantasy for all of human history
before him a supremacy over one's nature
and immortality he traveled the cosmos
he made millions and millions of
discoveries learned everything there was
to know every law of physics every rule
of reality all to end up here about to
die with everything else what was it all
for
clay wonders to himself what was the
point of beating his own death just to
be subjected to the death of the
universe how could a species that
transcended its own biology and the
nature of life itself just died off with
the universe like all the little
particles and amoebas that came before
it in the remaining moments of the
smothering universe clay decides to
create one last thing
now having learned all the mechanics of
nature and how the universe works clay
begins to construct the blueprint for a
new one like creating the rules of a
video game he renders the code for a new
universe he makes it hard but not
impossible
long but not without end he makes it so
each level gets a little more complex
yet a little more interesting a little
more daunting he had a little more
rewarding he makes it so the rules of
the universe change a little over time
never too far so it makes no sense but
never too close that it makes complete
sense he hides the end games
far from the starting point only in the
final stage can it be seen and
comprehended he conceals the truth
amidst the chaos the logic amidst the
disorder the meaning amidst the lack
thereof
finally he leaves the possibility for
creating anew clay finishes it's perfect
he says to himself the universe begins
to compress tighter and tighter the
dying energy dries out any remaining
life the last stars turn off the last
planets explode everything gives one
last nod a farewell to this existence as
it squeezes back into nothingness as the
energy tightens into a final pinpoint
clays new universe explodes a bursting
of colour matter and energy floods out
reversing the nothing into an ever
expanding everything time and space
begin again stars fill the sky celestial
collisions occur planets form bacteria
and amoebas flow around each other life
emerges in a trial and error of
existence unfolds a sequence of living
and dying trying and failing evolving
and adapting thinking and talking
building and creating years and years
and years would go by the year is 1968 a
seven year old boy named clay has just
finished building a contraption that
remotely opens and closes a little
outside door for his family's dog he is
constantly building toys and mechanical
contraptions like this one using spare
bike parts old TVs radios and any other
objects he can get his hands on he'll
probably do a lot in this life as clay
finishes the dog store his sister asks
him didn't you already make that yeah I
just took it apart and made it again
replies clay why asks his sister I don't
know it was fun and I wanted to see if I
could make it better
replies clay well is it better now asks
his sister clay replies no it was fine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you